[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليان الاختيار السهلوها بابره
العنب
امتثالا لمذكره محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وزير العدل الالمانيه تعاهدوا باعتقال
بوتين اذا قرر الاخير زياره المانيا
[موسيقى]
المئات من جنود الاحتياط الاسرائيليين
يرفضون قرار استدعائهم وانا ثانياه يحضر
من حاله عصيان داخل الجيش
يتم في هذا اليوم الاحد المصادف التاسع
عشر من شهر اذار لعام 2023 توقيع المحضر
الامني المشترك بين الجانب العراقي وبين
الجانب الايراني يمثل السيد
بعد دعوه
البيت الابيض يحذر من تكرار احداث
الكابيتول في السادس من يناير 2021
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تطورات مذكره الاعتقال التي
اصدرتها الجنايات الدوليه بحق الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين تعهد وزير العدل
الالماني باعتقال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
في حال قرر الاخير زياره المانيا امتثارا
لقرار محكمه الجنايات الدوليه وقال الوزير
الالماني في تصريحات نشرتها وسائل اعلام
المانيه ان محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
ستتواصل مع الانتربول لمطالبه الدول
الاعضاء بالامتثال لمذكره الاعتقال
الصادره بحق بوتين مشيرا الى ان المانيا
ستطبق هذه المذكره ومن برلين نفسها اعلن
السفير الروسي لدى المانيا وصفه تصريحات
الالمانيه بغير المسؤوله واعتبار تاييد
برلين للقرار مصدر قلق بالغ
هذا وتتوالى ردود الفعل الدوليه على اصدار
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره اعتقال
بحق الرئيس الروسي جنوب افريقيا اكدت انها
تدرك التزاماتها القانونيه اذا زار بوتين
جوهان لحضور قمه المقرره في اغسطس المقبل
وقال المتحدث باسم الرئيس ان جنوب افريقيا
ستتعامل مع كافه الجهات المعنيه بخصوص
زياره بوتين المحتمله وانها ستظل منخرطه
مع مختلف اصحاب المصلحه المعنيين في اشاره
الى عدم الامتثال للقرار وقرار المحكمه
الدوليه
بدوره حضر الرئيس الصربي من قرار اصدار
مذكره التوقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وبان عواقب هذا الامر سياسيه سيئه
وستقوض رفض الحديث عن السلام والهدنه في
اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان قرار اصدار مذكره توقيف في حق
بوتين ستكون له عواقب سياسيه سيئه ووخيمه
على حياه الناس مع الحديث ان هناك احجاما
كبيرا عن التطرق الى السلام والهدنه
لانقاذ حياه الكثيرين السؤال بعد ان اتهم
بارتكاب جرائم حرب الى من سيتم التحدث
الان الجميع ينتظر الهزيمه لكن كم سنه
سننتظر وهل من الممكن هزيمه روسيا في شهر
او ثلاثه او حتى سنه
قال الرئيس الروسي انه لا يزال يتعين على
بلاده بذل المزيد من الجهود لتطوير قواتها
العسكريه واوضح بوتين في تصريحات صحفيه
انه على الرغم من امتلاك روسيا اسلحه فرض
صوتيه لكنها لا تستخدمها مشيرا الى انه لم
يكن لدى روسيا اسلحه فرض صوتيه في عام
2014 وشدد بوتين على قوه النظام المالي في
روسيا رغم توقعات سلبيه بانهياره لمن
وصفهم بالاعداء في اشاره للدول الغربيه
وافشان الاوكرانيه اضاف بوتين ان روسيا لم
تستطع ان ترفض طلب دعم سكان شبه جزيره
القرم في عام 2014 وجدد رئيس الروسي
تاكيده ان روسيا انطلقت من امكانيه تصفيه
الوضع في اوكرانيا سلميا ولم ترغب في
المواجهه
وفي اول زياره له الى اقليم دومباس منذ
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا تجول الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في مدينه ماريوبل
الاوكرانيه وتفقد عددا من المرافق فيها
زياره يقول مراقبها انها تحمل الكثير من
الرسائل
مترجلا يتجول بوتين في ماريوبول اشهر
المدن الاوكرانيه في ذاكره العالم هنا قاد
سيارته بنفسه وهنا وقف تحت نصب اوكرانيين
يعلوه على مرسي وقفه برسائل ودلالات كثيره
الرئيس الروسي اختار المدينه التي تشكل
رمزا للمقاومه الاوكرانيه وقلب اوكرانيا
الصناعي واقربها الى خط نار المعارك
المستعره منذ سنه ونيف الزياره المفاجئه
تعتبر الاولى لبوتين الى المناطق التي
استولت عليها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتاتي بعد يومين فقط من اصدار
مذكره توقيف بحقه وبالتزامن مع الذكرى
التاسعه لضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرن وفقا
لوسائل اعلام الروسيه فان سيد الكرملين
زار مدرسه ومركزا للاطفال في شبه جزيره
القرش عرض يقول مراقبه انه تحدي لمن اتهمه
بقتل اطفال اوكرانيا وترحيل الاف منهم الى
روسيا
الملك تاتي زياره قبل زياره مرتقبه لشي
جينغ بينج حليف بوتين الابرز وفي وقت
يتكتل فيه حلفاء كييف الغربيون لدعم
هجومها المرتقب في الربيع هجوم تقول انها
تريد من خلاله استعاده اراضيها المسلوبه
ما بينما استولت عليه موسكو وما تريده
كييف وقف بوتي وقفه قال فيها الكثير وان
لم يتحدث رائد المصطفى العربيه
وفي رد فعل على هذه الزياره انتقد مساعده
رئاسه الاوكرانيه بخياله بدولياك تواجد
الرئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين بمدينه
ماريوبل الساحليه التي استولت عليها
القوات الروسيه العام الماضي ووصف بدولاك
بوتين بالمجرم الذي يعود دائما الى مسرح
الجريمه وانه قتل الالاف في ماريوبل وهو
سعيد بمشاهده المدينه ومقابلها وغير نادم
على حد وصف بدولاك
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايب
ميكيافو مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
استاذ يفين كيف تقراون قرار العدل الدوليه
طبعا بظل عدم اعتراف روسيا بهذا القرار
وهي اصلا لا تعترف بالمحكمه ككل
مساء الخير تحيه من كيف شكرا على استضافتي
طبعا نحن كنا منتظرين لهي قرار وقرار مهم
جدا ولو كتير من الدول لا
اتفقوا ولا تعترفوا محكمه الدوليه بما في
ذلك امريكا على فكره اوكرانيا قد وقعت كل
الوثائق
المتخصصه بهاي المحكمه ولكن لسه ما كانت
ابرام بهاي قرار اعتراف محكمه ولكن قرار
عادل ومهم جدا
123 دوله هي هي عدد كبير اللي يعترف تعترف
بهاي محكمه دوليه
خلينا لا لا نستعجل نجد من يعيش نشوف نعم
ولكن يعني بنفس السياق هناك اتهامات
للمحكمه بان هذا القرار هو سياسي بحث ولا
يمد يعني للموضوع الانساني بصله وذهب
الروس الى سرد سرديات تاريخيه ان كان عن
موضوع غزو العراق او غيرها او حتى عن
اطفال سوريا وكل الجرائم التي لم يحاسب
مرتكبها لماذا اليوم فقط الرئيس الروسي
يعني تنسب اليه هذه التهم او يتم يعني
اصدار تهمه بحق
هناك كانت اديله
بدورط
قياده الروسيه
في بدء هذا الحرب يعني
غير عادله وحرب غير معروفه يعني غير يعني
ولا احد كان ينتظر
وقرار عادل جدا في بعض الاحيان الروسي
يقولون بان
شوفوا على امريكا ماذا فعل امريكا في
العراق ماذا فعلت في يوغسلافيا او في
الدول الاخرى ولكن للاسف الشديد الان
روسيا تعرف تعمل نفس الشيء في اوكرانيا
منذ سنه وانا اريد كمان ان اذكركم شيء
واحد مهم
بان
زياره
صاحب كريملين
الصوت متقطع
[موسيقى]
لا نستطيع ان نسمع اي شيء شكرا لك
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني حدثنا
[موسيقى]
مخاوف جديه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي من
عصيان محتمل داخل اروقه الجيش فيما
الاحتجاجات ضد تعديل خطه النظام القضائي
تدخل الاسبوع الحادي عشر ورئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو يقول ان
البعض يطالب باغلاق الطرق والعصيان وسفك
الدماء في الشوارع والحاق الاذى بشخصيات
العامه وشاديدا على ان الحكومه لن تقبل
بالفوضى والعنف من اي جانب متوقعا من رئيس
الاركان والرؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه ان
يقاوموا العصيان بقوه كما اعلن عشرات
الطيارين الحربيين ومشاغري طائرات من دون
طيار انهم لن يمثلوا في خدمه الاحتياط
خلال الاسبوعين المقبلين كي يتمكنوا من
المشاركه في المظاهرات ضد خطه اضعاف جهاز
القضاء وفق قولهم طبعا بدورها اعلنت
المحكمه العدل العليا الاسرائيليه عن منع
وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن غفير من اعطاء
تعليمات عمليه للشرطه خصوصا اثناء
الاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه واكدت المحكمه ان
هذه التوجيهات ضروريه من اجل تجنب
النزاعات في المستقبل كما انها تجنب
التوجيهات السياسيه للشرطه خلال حدث لا
يزال جاريه
[موسيقى]
تظاهرات الاحتجاج الحاشده واصرار الحكومه
على المضيف خطه تغيير نظام القضاء واضعاف
المحكمه العليا وسط تحضيرات متواتره من ان
تقود بوادر العنف الى حرب اهليه
كما دوما فاننا امام امكاني تدهور امني
على عده جبهات وممنوع علينا ان تدور حرب
اخوه على جبهتنا الداخليه نتنياهو توقف
على الاقل الى ما بعد شهر رمضان
الخشيه لدى القياده العسكريه والامنيه من
ان يؤدي وصول الانقسام الى صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى انهيار موقع الاجماع شبه
الوحيد في المجتمع الاسرائيلي وان تتراجع
معنويات القتال فيما تنتظر اسرائيل تحديات
خارجيه فايران تلامس القدره النوويه
العسكريه وحزب الله اختبر اسرائيل في
عمليه مجدو في العمق وتم التخوف من اندلاع
حرب جديده على قطاع غزه وانفجار الوضع في
الضفه في شهر رمضان المغترب
بعد ان وصل الانقسام في الشارع الاسرائيلي
الى صفوف الجيش من خلال موجه رفض الخدمه
من قبل نخب قتاليه في الاحتياط يرى
مراقبون بان ذلك سيمس بجاهزيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي القتاليه في مواجهه تحديات
قريبه وبعيده وقد يؤدي الى اختبار جهات
خارجيه للواقع الاسرائيلي المازوم عسكريا
وهو يقرا ضعفا ووهنا زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه
للحادثه اكثر عن هذا الملف ينضم الينا من
القدس الدكتور مصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه
في الجامعه العبريه
يعني من المعلوم بان قوه اسرائيل هي بجيشه
وان يعني ما ارتكز عليه نتنياهو منذ ان
اتى الى السلطه وحتى اليوم هو موضوع
الدفاع عن اسرائيل الموضوع الامني تحديدا
اليوم عندما يصل العصيان الى المؤسسه
الامنيه ماذا يعني ذلك على حكم وعلى ولايه
نتانياهو
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه استاذي كريمه
وتحياتي للجميع اولا قوه اسرائيل ليست في
جيشها وانما في ديمقراطيتها في حرياتها في
نظامها الدستوري ولا شكر في انه هذا شق
اخر
وبالتالي طبعا لا يشك في انه ما يحدث رغم
انه الحديث هو عدد قليل من المجندين
اولا لن يؤثر على العمل عمل القوى الامن
والجيش وثانيا كذلك انه حتى هذه اللحظه
حتى هذه اللحظه تاتي هذه الخطوات في اطار
الشرائح حيث
كيف لا تؤثر على عمل الجيش اذا كانت
القوات الاسرائيليه اتحدث يعني بالحروب
وبالاشياء المصيريه تستعين بقوات الاحتياط
دائما
نعم ولكن الحديث هنا من ضمن عشرات الالاف
من الاحتياط الحديث هنا عن 450 فرد 450
فرد فقط
وهمم امتنعوا عن
تمرينات اختياريه تمرينات اختياريه كما
انه الجنود والضباط الذين شاركوا فيها
المظاهرات حتى هذه اللحظه حصلوا على
موافقه من القضاء العسكري القضاء العسكري
سمح لهم شريطه ان الان يتظاهروا بذي
المدني وليس بالزي العسكري اذا حتى هذه
اللحظه الاشياء تسير في في اطار اشر ولكن
في اطار التوسع توسع رقعه الاحتجاجات بوجه
قرار الحكومه مع التهديد بان زوال النظام
الديمقراطي وزوال اسس التي قامت عليها
اسرائيل هو يعني تحضير الى زوالا هذا ما
يقول المعارضين في الداخل ماذا يعني ذلك
لا شك انه رمزيا رمزيا هناك خطوره شديده
في انه يتم تسييس
المؤسسه العسكريه حيث ان الحكومه اليوم
اصبحت في صدام كما ذكرت في اكثر من مناسبه
ليس مع الشارع او مع المعارضه النيابيه
وانما مع الدوله الحكومه اصبح في صدام
شامل ومفتوح مع مؤسسات الدوله مع الجيش مع
الشرطه مع القضاء وبالتالي طبعا هذه هذه
هذا هو هذا المشهد هو خطير للغايه وما
يحدث اليوم هو غير مسبوق وانا اعتقد انه
لم تعد هناك خيارات كثيره امام الحكومه
هذه المظاهرات لن يعني ليس لا يوجد سبب
موضعي حتى
تكف المعارضه او يكف المتظاهرون عن تظاهري
وبالتالي اعتقد انه ليس بيل الا
الحوار مع المعارضه تحت خيمه الرئاسه هناك
مبادره قدمها رئيس الدوله وهذه المبادره
هي تحتوي على تنازلات كثيره قبلت بها
المعارضه انا اعتقد انه هذا هو سبيل
الوحيد للخروج من الازمه التي اصبحت اليوم
تحولت من ازمه سياسيه الى ازمه دستوريه
هذه الازمه الدستوريه التي انسحبت
لتصبح ازمه شعبيه وازمه ثقه اليوم بين
الشارع وبين الحكومه هذا الحوار هل ممكن
ان يعني يحل بطريقه جذريه ويتراجع نتنياهو
عن الاصلاحات وعن التعديلات التي يطالب
فيها
انا اعتقد انه بديهيا لا يوجد خيار اخر
واليوم اصبحت الضغوط التي تمارس على سيده
نيو ائتلافه تاتي كانت من المعارضه ربما
من مؤسسات الدوله الحكومه تسميها الدوله
العميق دوله عميقه نحن نسميها الشرعيه
وكذلك من الخارج من اصدقاء السئيل في
الخارج ولا يستعمل الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده
مجتمع مدني صديق لاسرائيل اليوم اصبح هناك
عنصر ضغط جديد ياتي من قلب الليكول ليس من
المنشقين عن الليكود الذين هم في المعارضه
اليوم ولكن عن اعضاء كنيسه محسوبين على
الريقود كرئيس الكنيسه الازرق
واخرين وزراء سابقين غير مقربين من سنه
ليس لديهم حقائب وزاريه ولكنهم نواب في
كنيسه عن حسب اليكود اليوم اصبحوا ينادون
بالدخول في حوار جاد مع المعارضه في اطار
لاخراج هذا الموضوع شكرا لك دكتور مصري
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه
على هذه المنتخب
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
احدهما في حاله خطيره اصابه مستوطنين
باطلاقنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعتقال منفذ اطلاق النار على مستوطنين في
بلده حواره جنوب نابلس والذي اسفر عن
اصابه مستوطنين اثنين احدهما في حاله
خطيره واوضح الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان ان
منفذ العمليه تم اعتقاله بعد مطارده مشيرا
الى اصابه منفذ الهجوم وبان التحقيق جاري
معه
اصدرت مصر والاردن والولايات المتحده
واسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه بيانا
المشتركا بشان اجتماع اليوم في شرم الشيخ
واكدت اكد البيان على ضروره تحقيق الهدنه
على الارض ووقف العنف بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين كما جددت اسرائيل والسلطه
الفلسطينيه وقف الاجراءات الاحاديه لفتره
بين ثلاثه الى سته اشهر مع وقف مناقشه
المستوطنات الجديده
لاربعه اشهر ايضا اعلن البيان عن استحداث
اليه لوقف العنف وتحريض مع رفع تقارير الى
قيادات الدول الخمس مع ضروره ضمان مواجهه
اي استفزازات في المواقع المقدسه بما في
ذلك خلال شهر رمضان كما اكد البيان ارسال
اليه من اجل تحسين الوضع الاقتصادي للشعب
الفلسطيني البيان اكد ايضا ان اسرائيل
وسلطه الفلسطينيه اتفقتها على الالتزام
بكل الاتفاقات السابقه بينهما كما تقرر
استمرار الاجتماعات على المستوى الخماسي
من اجل وضع اساس لاجراء مفاوضات مباشره
بين الفلسطينيين وال اسرائيليين للتواصل
الى سلام
[موسيقى]
الى العراق حيث وقع مجلس الوزراء اتفاقيه
امنيه مشتركه مع ايران في حضور رئيس
الوزراء محمد شاع السوداني هذا وذكر مكتب
رئيس الوزراء العراقي انه اكد خلال لقائه
رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الايراني علي
شامخاني موقف بلاده الرافض لان تكون
العراق منطلقا للاعتداء على اي من دول
الجوار واضاف البيان ان الاتفاق الامني
المشترك بين طهران وبغداد يهدف التنسيق
لحمايه بين البلدين وتوطيد التعاون في
مجالات امنيه عده هذا وافاد مراسل عربيه
بان الاتفاق العراقي الايراني ينص على ضبط
الحدود بين اقليم كردستان وايران وزياده
عدد المخافر الحدوديه بين العراق وايران
وفق الاتفاق
في العراق ايضا لكن في الذكرى العشرين
للحرب على تلك البلاد والتي لا تزال
تداعياتها مستمره الى يومنا هذا سواء
دوليا او داخل العراق نفسه
[موسيقى]
قبل عقدين من الزمن تغير المشهد في العراق
راسا على عقب بعد قرار الولايات المتحده
شن حرب على العراق وهو ما تبنته بريطانيا
بحجه وجود اسلحه دمار شامل بحوزه النظام
العراقي الذي كان على راسه رئيس الاسباق
صدام حسين ليله التاسع عشر من اذار عام
2003 اطلق الرئيس الامريكي انذاك جورج
دبليو بوش حمله اطاحه صدام التي اطلق
عليها الصدمه والترويع بقصف عنيف استهدف
بغداد في محاوله لقتل صدام حسين وهو ما لم
يتحقق لتنطلق الحرب البريه
160 الف جندي امريكي ارسل حينها الى ارض
العراق ولم تدم الحرب طويلا ومع بدايه اي
بريل انهار جيش صدام ودخل الامريكيون
العاصمه العراقيه بدوره كشف بول برايمر
المبعوثه الرئاسي الامريكي السابق الى
العراق تفاصيل بالغه الاهميه للشرق الاوسط
معترفا بارتكابه خطا ومؤكدا حتى لو عاد
بهم الزمن عشرين عاما الى الوراء فان
التحرك نحو الاطاحه بالرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين كان قرارا صائبا
حكم العراق لاكثر من عام بصفته رئيسا
لسلطه الائتلاف المؤقته
اسرار العراق لعقدين من الزمن يعترف
لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط بارتكاب خطاين
رئيسيين ضمن المهمه التي اصدر خلالها مئه
من المراسيم اولها اجتثاث تفكيك البعث
والثاني حل الجيش العراقي
لكنه بالرغم من ذلك اصر على صوابيه قرار
الحرب وضروره الاطاحه بصدام حسين وبحسب
بريمير مهما كان وضع العراق فانه يبقى
افضل حالا بعد 20 عاما برحيل صدام
مضيفا انه لو بقي صدام في السلطه لاصبح
العالم امام قوتين نوويتين على الاقل هما
ايران والعراق
تلاشت ذكرياتها لكن اثارها ما تزال مستمره
حرب العراق حطمت ثقه الشعب البريطاني
بحكومته رغم مرور 20 عاما تقول صحيفه
الجاردين البريطانيه المملكه المتحده
اليوم تعاني اكثر من اي وقت مضى من السخط
الشعبي والقلق بسبب عدم ثقه البريطانيين
بحكومتهم بعدما شاركت الولايات المتحده
بقرار الحرب على العراق الذكرى العشرون
تذكر باكبر كارثه سياسيه وانسانيه تورطت
فيها المملكه المتحده منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والسبب كان رئيس الحكومه
البريطانيه السابق توني بلير والذكرى تذكر
ايضا باللحظه التي بدا فيها مركز الثقل
السياسي المفترض في بريطانيا يترنح على
نحو متهور وكارثي بحسب الصحيفه البريطانيه
التي اعادت التذكير بان حزب المحافظين
والغالبيه العظمى من الصحافه البريطانيه
دعموا حرب العراق حين ها وعليه تشدد
الجارديان بان الذكرى السنويه لتلك الحرب
المدمره تعد مثالا حيا على مخاطر التفكير
على نحو جماعي والنتائج القاتمه التي يفضي
اليها اختزال الحقائق المعقده في روايات
بسيطه قبل ان نكمل دعونا نشاهد بعض هذه
المشاهد من تلك الحرب ونعود
وتضيف الجارديان بان العود او انه بالعوده
سريعا الى تقارير الصادره خلال الحرب تجعل
المرء يدرك الفجوه العميقه التي شكلتها
تلك الاحداث بين السلطه وسياساتها من جهه
وجمهور الشعب البريطاني من جهه اخرى
تداعيات لم تنتهي هنا فقرار المشاركه في
الحرب ضد العراق للتخصص جل رئيس الوزراء
السابق توني بلير السياسي لبل وقضى على
رؤيه حزب العمال التي كانت تقدم بريطانيا
بصفاتها دوله فتيه واثقه من نفسها اما
الشعب العراقي الذي يعاني جروحا كبيره
ويعيش ازمات متلاحقه وفي المنطقه ككل ما
زالوا يعانون يوميا بسبب تداعيات تلك
الحرب فيما لا تزال التركيبه السياسيه
الشيعيه محافظه على مكانتها باعتبارها
المستفيد الاول من سقوط نظام الرئيس
السابق صدام حسين وفق مراقبين للتطورات
الحاصله
بعد عقدين من الزمن ما زالت تركيبه
السياسيه على حالها في العراق حتى مع
تغيير اتجاهاتها ومسمياتها الكتله
السياسيه الشيعيه المستفيد الاول من سقوط
نظام صدام حسين قبل 20 عاما وتكون حصه
الاسد من نصيبها في نظام ما بعد صدام فهي
اليوم باتت تمسك بمفاصل المشهد السياسي
برمته في العراق وتحت رقابه الحليفه ايران
وسط توازن هش ومتقلب محليا وحتى اقليميا
الصوره تبدو واضحه في الفضاء العام سواء
بصور رجال الدين العراقيين وغير العراقيين
المنتشره في كل الشوارع او من خلال احياء
المناسبات الدينيه التي كانت تقام بالسر
قبل عام 2003 هيمنه على الحياه السياسيه
بعد حرمان دام لفتره طويله من التمثيل
السياسي في ظل النظام القديم الذي اطاحت
به واشنطن حيث شرعت السلطات المؤقته
نصبتها الولايات المتحده في بناء نظام
سياسي جديد مع حلفائها واقامه توازن هش
للسلطه القائم على المحاصصه وتوزيع
المناصب بشكل رئيسي بين الشيعه والاكراد
والسنه مع نسب صغيره لبعض الاقليات
الدينيه والقوميه
طيله هذه الفتره هيمنه الاسماء نفسها على
البيت الشيعي وهي التسميه التي اطلقها
المراقبون على الطبقه السياسيه التقليديه
من نور المالك وهادي العامري وعمار الحكيم
والقائمه تطول كما ان اساسيات النظام لم
تتغير الى حد كبير فالقواعد التي ارسلتها
النخبه في عام 2003 وحتى 2005 مازالت تحكم
الحياه السياسيه حتى الان
تضارب المصالح والبحث عن النفوذ داخل
اركان البيت الشعير دفع الخلافات للظهور
الى العلن لتبلغ ذروتها في اعقاب
الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره في عام 2021
لتتحول بعدها الى صدام مسلح على اسوار
المنطقه الخضراء في اغسطس 2022 بيوم من
القتال الدم في بغداد وما زال معظم
العراقيين الذين ولدوا بعد عام 2003 يمنون
النفس بدوله يحكمها القانون لينعموا
بخيرات هذا البلد الذي لم يعرف طعم
الاستقرار منذ زمن ليس بالقصير
ينضم الينا من عمان محمد سلمان الطائي عضو
اتحاد البرلمانيين العراقيين استاذ محمد
بعد 20 عام على الغزول الامريكي للعراق ما
الذي تحصن او ما الذي نتج عن هذا الغزو
غير تحكم يعني الطرف الشيعي الايراني بهذه
الدوله وجعل مصدر تهديد للمنطقه اجمع
مساء الخير سيدتي الكريمه ما جرى في
العراق هي اكبر مؤامره دوليه حاكتها
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا بحجج كاذبه
وواهيه لاحتلال الدوله العراقيه وتحطيمها
العراق اليوم دوله فاشله بكل
المعطيات السياسيه والاقتصاديه والامنيه
العراق يحكم منذ 20 عام بعقليه دينيه
الاحزاب السياسيه التي تحكم العراق الان
هي احزاب دينيه لم يسمح لاي طرف مدني او
علماني او وطني ان يقترب من رئاسه الحكومه
او من مؤسسه صنع القرار
لذلك العراقي اليوم بيئه كبيره لتفشي
المخدرات نسب الفساد لا شبيهه لها في
العالم كله
والمجتمع العراقي انت تحت خطوط الفقر
والجهل والميليشيات والمخدرات
وانفتاح الحدود وكل الاشياء السلبيه التي
لا توجد دوله في العالم تعاني مثل ما
يعاني العراقيين بعد 20 عام استاذ محمد
يعني عندما اتى الغزو اتى لارساء نظام
ديمقراطي ودوله حقيقيه داخل العراق اليوم
بعد 20 عام الدوله منهاره دوله غنيه هي
الافقر في العالم ودول منطقه الشعب يان من
يعني من الجوع من كل
مسببات هذا النظام والفساد وايضا يعني
تقسيم داخلي بطريقه غريبه ما الذي يعني
بعد 20 عام ما الذي يمكن قوله عن هذا
الغزو
كل الذي نستطيع ان نقوله الان ان العراق
بكل مقدراته السياسيه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه يدار من قبل ايران حصرا هامش
التاثير الامريكي في العراق اخذ في
الانحسار كل الحكومات تتشكل برعايه
ايرانيه
القرارات في الدوله العراقيه وان وجدت
مؤسسات شكليه لكن الايحاءات والضغط ايراني
20 عام انتجت حقيقه واحده ان العراق الان
مسيطره علي سيطره مطلقه من الايرانيين هم
يتحكمون بمصادر القرار يتحكمون بمصادر
الثروه يتحكمون بسياسه العراق الخارجيه
بحيث اصبح العراق يعني جعلوا العراق واحد
من اكبر مخالبهم في المنطقه هذه هي حصيله
عشرين عام من الاحتلال الامريكي للعراق
ومن
من عام ايضا كان يعني الحرب المنطلق من
الحرب هو تدمير اسلحه النوويه واسلحه
الدمار الموجوده مع نظام الرئيس الراحل
اليوم العراق كل تحول الى قنبله موقوته
بالمنطقه واستسيطره المليشيات هناك ووسط
كل الفوضى الموجوده ودخل من حاله الحرب
الى حاله الفوضى يعني ماذا يعني ذلك على
فشل الامريكيين هناك
هذا الكلام صحيح العراقي اليوم
يعني بفعل التحكم الايراني بمفاصل الدوله
العراقيه مفتوح على كل الاحتمالات السلبيه
تجاه محيطه سواء العربي او التركي هو اداه
بيد الايرانيين الراي العام العراقي الان
وبعد مرور 20 سنه على الاحتلال والتدمير
بدا يدرك بدا هنالك مقوله تقولي يبدو ان
الامريكان الغايه الحقيقيه من احتلال
العراق ليس البحث عن اسلحه الدمار الشامل
وانما تسليم العراق الى ايران المشروع
الامريكي كان يقوم على اساس اخضاع الدوله
العراقيه
وتركيعها لصالح ايران وهذا ما تثبته 20
عام مضى الوقائع شكرا لك محمد سلمان عضو
اتحاد البرلمانيين العراقيين على هذه
المداخله
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني الحسين امير
عبد الله انه سيلتقي وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان قريبا
نشيرا الى انه تم اقتراح ثلاثه اماكن لعقد
الاجتماع واضاف وزير خارجيه ايران انه تم
الاتفاق مع السعوديه على زياره وفد او
وفود فنيه للسفرتين تحضيرا لاعاده
افتتاحها
ستلتقي وزير الخارجيه السعوديه في القريب
العاجل حتى ذلك الحين اتفقنا على وجوب
تبادل زياره الوفود الفنيه الدبلوماسيه
والقنصليه وبدء اعاده فتح السفارات اعلنت
ايران عن استعدادها لعقد قمه لوزراء
الخارجيه مع السعوديه وقدمت ثلاثه
اقتراحات لتحديد مكان هذه القمه وسيتم
اختيار الزمان والمكان على اساس الاتفاق
بين الجانبين وذلك في اقرب وقت ممكن
بانضمام عمال توتال معارضون التقاعد
الجديد بفرنسا يستمرون في التعبير عن
غضبهم عبر الاحتجاج والاضرار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت سلطات الصحيه
السودانيه ارتفاع الاصابات المؤكده بحمى
الضنك في الخرطوم الى الف واثنتين واربعين
حاله 20 منها من العاملين ضمن الكوادر
الطبيه
ودعت وزاره الصحه المصابين والمشبه في
اصابتهم بالمرض الى عدم تعاطي اي علاجات
بخلاف اخذ السوائل اللازمه وقالت الوزراء
ان محليه امبدا في ام درمان او محليه
امبدا في ام درمان سجلت اعلى نسب الاصابه
بالمرض
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده واخر تطورات قضيه
ترامب مع ممثله امريكيه حيث حذر المدعي
العام في منطقه من هاتف في نيويورك من
التعرض للمحققين العاملين في القضيه
الخاصه بالرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب
مضيفا انه لن يتهاون مع محاولات ترهيب
المحققين بينما قال مستشار الامن القومي
في البيت الابيض جون كاربي انه لم يتم رصد
تهديدات امنيه بعد دعوه ترامب لانصاره
بتجمع ترقبا لاصدار امر اعتقال ضده من
جهته عبر مايك بانس نائب رئيس الامريكي
السابق عن استغرابه من ان المدعي العام في
منهات يعتقد ان توجيه الاتهام الى رئيس
الولايات المتحده السابق هو اولويه قصوى
[موسيقى]
فوجئت بفكره اتهام الرئيس السابق للولايات
المتحده في وقت كانت هناك موجه اجراميه في
مدينه نيويورك وحقيقه ان المدعي العام في
منهات يعتقد ان توجيه الاتهام الى ترامب
هو اولويه قصوى اعتقد ان الامر يخبرنا بما
نحتاجه لمعرفته اليسار اراديكالي في هذا
البلد يبدو وكان الامر محاكمه مشحونه
سياسيه وهذا ما لا يحتاجه الشعب الامريكي
في ظل التحديات الحاليه والشعور بوجود
نظام عداله من مستويين في هذا البلد اذا
حدث هذا الامر الثلاثاء فيجب ان يتم بشكل
سلمي وبطريقه قانونيه
لا تقدم على تهامه ترامب في حال لم تكن
متاكدا لانه اذا ثبتت براءه ترامب سيكتب
المؤرخين ان هذه القضيه اعادته الى البيت
الابيض رئيسا من الباب العريض ففي اخر
تطورات قضيه ترامب والممثله الاباحيه
الامريكيه قدم مستشار الامن القومي السابق
للبيت الابيض جون بولتن نصيحه لمدعي عام
بعد تسريبات من مكتبه تتحدث عن اعتقال
ترامب يوم الثلاثاء القادم الرئيس السابق
ترامب كان سبق الاحداث ودعا انصاره الى
تنظيم احتجاجات لاستعاده الامه لمنع
اعتقاله وهذا الامر احدث ضجه في الداخل
الامريكي ومخاوف كبيره من ان يلجا انصار
ترامب الى العنف على غرار ما حصل في
السادس من يناير عام
2021 عندما اقتحم مناصروه مبنى الكونجرس
ونتج عنها طبعا فوض ى كان يمكن ان تؤدي
الى حرب اهليه وهو ما حذر منه البيت
الابيض قبل نحو ساعتين من الان
وفي المقابله مع القضاء الامريكي الى
التاكد من صحه الاتهامات وتاكد من انه اي
القضاء سيدين ترامب 100% فن السماء
ولم تتم ادانته فعل المؤرخين ان يسجلوا ان
هذا الاجراء هو الذي اعاد انتخاب ترامب
رئيسا لاجل ذلك اتمنى على القضاه ان
يكونوا واثقين تماما من قضيتهم
احتمال اعتقال ترامب دفع بقاده جمهوريين
الى الدفاع عنه وهو ما قام به رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي الذي امر بالتحقيق مع من
يحقق مع ترامب وهو المدعي العام الامريكي
الشعب الامريكي له حق دستوري في التجمع
السلمي وعلى مناصري ترامب الاحتجاج بطريقه
سلميه هكذا علق نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق مايك بانس على دعوه ترامب مناصريه
للاحتجاج ليرد هنا مدعي عام من هاتم
بالقول حازما بانه ينصق مع الشرطه نيويورك
لحمايه المحققين من اي تهديدات ولن يتسامح
مع محاولات راب لتهديد المحققين ولكن ربما
لن تبدا محاكمه ترامب قبل اكثر من عام وقد
تتزامن مع الاشهر الختاميه للحمله
الانتخابيه لرئاسه البيت الابيض في عام
2024 والتي يسعى فيها ترامب للعوده طبعا
الى المكتب البيضاوي يقول هنا خبراء
الحقوقيه
كيف تؤثر مشكلات ترامب القانونيه على
مساعيه للرئاسه في 2024
دستوريا لم تحدد اي ماده الاتهامات او
الادانات الجنائيه التي تطال مؤهلات
الرئيس
زمنيا ربما يضطر ترامب للمثول للمحاكمه في
منتصف حملته الرئاسيه او حتى بعد
الانتخابات
اي قضيه جنائيه تستغرق اكثر من عام لتتحول
من مجرد اتهامات الى محاكمه اذا جرى
انتخاب ترامب لن يتمتع بسلطه العفو عن
نفسه في اتهامات موجهه بموجب قانون ولايه
لكن احاله الرئيس المنتخب للمحاكمه ستدخل
حينها حيزا قانونيا مجهولا
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن هذه القضيه تنضم
الينا في الاستوديو نادي البلبيسي مديره
مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه باخر وجود
وجود لك معنا في دبي لماذا يعني هذا الخوف
من قبل ترامب اذا كنا نتحدث عن سنه لكي
ياخذ مجرى قانوني يعني على ابواب
الانتخابات او ضمن الحمله الانتخابيه يعني
البعض يرى ليال بانها استفاده للرئيس حتى
يشحن مؤيديه حتى يستمر في ادعاءاته بانه
هناك ملاحقه من قبل الديمقراطيين بان هناك
تسييس لهذا الموضوع لنذكر المشاهدين بانه
اتهم سابقا بانه حاول ان يعطي اموال
لممثله اباحيه عن طريق محاميه الذي قضى
ثلاث سنوات بالسجن وهو مايكل كوين طبعا
والان المحقق او المدعي العام في نيويورك
يقول بانه هنا هذا ملف الرئيس ليس
القانون وبالتالي سيعامل مثل اي مواطن
امريكي لكن كما تعرفين هو الرئيس السابق
وبالتالي لا يوجد هناك ربما اي سابقه في
التاريخ الامريكي لرئيس يمكن ان يجرب طبعا
حتى الان نتحدث عن لائحه اتهام لا نتحدث
عن ادانا او تسجيم او سجن او الى اخره
وبالتالي الرئيس ترامب معروف بانه اتى من
خلفيه التلفزيون هو ما يسمى بالاجنده اي
يريد دوما ان يكون هناك يعني تركيز
للانظار عليه ويريد ان يقول لمتابعه بانه
ضحيه وان المدعي العام هو ديمقراطي
وبالتالي هذا الاتهام ياتي الان بالتحديد
فقط لانه ديمقراطي يعني دعوه ترامب
لمناصريه للنزول الى الشارع اتت بعد ساعات
من عودته الى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي حتى
وان كانت الدعوه قد يعني وضعها على تروس
سوشيال ميديا للتابعه له هذه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي كانت العامل الاساسي
التي ساهمت بنجاح حملته في المره الماضيه
ما دلاله هذا الموضوع الرئيس يستعد
للانتخابات القادمه عشرين 24 يعرف بان
هناك الكثير من المرشحين طبعا
حاكمه ولايه السابقه ترشحت اعلنت رسميا
وايضا الرئيس ترامب وهناك حديث عن مايك
بينس نائب الرئيس ومايك وزير الخارجيه
وغيره وبالتالي الرئيس يريد ان يكون دوما
بالصداره ان يحاول ان ربما ان يفشل اي
محاوله لربطه باتهامات سابقه ويقول بانها
مسيسه وبالتالي كما تعرفون هناك 30% من
الحزب الجمهوري مؤيدين للرئيس بغض النظر
وراينا اليوم على فكره رئيس ذهب من مر
العرج وهو منتجعه في ولايه فلوريدا الى
وكان هناك
احتفال به وكانه لا يتحدث عن اعتقال يوم
الثلاثاء ونحن لا نعرف يعني هي تسريبات
قالت ترامب انه وصلته من مكتب المدعي
العام رغم انه البعض يقول بانه كان هناك
استدعاء لاخر شاهد في هذه القضيه ويمكن
بالفعل حسب المصادر الامريكيه بانه يمكن
للمدعي العام ان يصدر مذكره باعتقال ترامب
خلال الاسبوع القادم هل هو يوم الثلاثاء
او يوم الاربعاء لا نعرف هل بالفعل سيقوم
باعتقاله لا نعرف لكن بالنسبه للرئيس دوما
دوما يحاول ان يكون هو بالصداره وبالسبق
لاي حدث وكان معه او ضده حتى يحشد الراي
العام حتى يقول لمتابعيه بانه ضحيه بانه
هناك ما يسمى يعني ملاحقه له الى اي مدى
سيستفيد منها بالحمله الانتخابيه خصوصا
اذا لم تاتي يعني باي ادعاء قانوني
بالمعنى الجرمي سيستفيد منها بالنسبه
لمتابعي سيرسخ هذه القاعده التي قالها قبل
ان يصبح مرشحا لو راني اقتل شخصا في فئه
افينيورك سيقول بانني ليس ترامب هو الذي
قام بذلك وبالتالي هم مخلصين له يضمن
ولائهم ويؤكد مره اخرى بانه الصحيه الذي
يدافع عنهم عن وجودهم ضده اكيد لانه كما
تعرف الذي يعارض الرئيس دوما سيعارضه
ويقول بانه لديه مشاكل قانونيه كبيره
قضائيه سواء كانت
موضوع هذه الممثله الاباحيه او موضوع ستي
يناير والاهم شكرا لك ناديان مكتب العربيه
في واشنطن على وجودك معنا
مشاهدينا تسببت
استمرار الاحتجاجات على قانون رفع سن
التقاعد في فرنسا في تعطيل اعمال الصيانه
في مفاعلات نوويه كانت فرنسا تنوي اعاده
استخدامها بعد ازمه الطاقه فيما انضم نحو
35% من عمال توتال انرجي للطاقه الى
الاضرابات وهذه الصور للاحتكاكات وبين
المتظاهرين ضد قانون التقاعد الجديد
والشرطه الفرنسيه فلنتابعها
[موسيقى]
يلا
الى باكستان حيث واجهت الشرطه الباكستانيه
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
من مساعده وعشرات من انصاره بالارهاب
اضافه الى جرائم اخرى تتعلق باشتباك انصار
عمران مع قوات الامن في اسلام اباد يوم
السبت وكان عدد كبير من المؤيدين لعمران
خان رشقوا بالحجاره عناصر الشرطه الذين
ردوا باطلاق الغاز المسيل للدموع امام
مجمع المحاكم في اسلام اباد
من باكستان الى جارتها افغانستان عمليات
دمويه تبنى مسؤولياتها تنظيم داعش واخر
هذه العمليات الانتحاريه قتل فيها حاكم
لمقاطعه بلا خشماليه ما هو حجم عناصر داعش
في افغانستان وهل التنظيم يشكل تهديدا على
الامن هناك فلنتابع
خالد جدران متحدث باسم قياده الامن في
العاصمه كابول يعترف بان عناصر من تنظيم
داعش اختفوا في البلاد بعدما دخل الطالبان
العاصمه وقامت بكسر ابواب السجون التابعه
للنظام السابق التي كان يقمع فيها عدد من
معتقل التنظيم
قوتنا الامنيه جاده في التصدي لجميع
العناصر الشريره التي تهدد الامن وتضايق
المواطنين نحن نقوم باحتقالهم وقتلهم
حيثما ظهرنا بهم
مهاجر فراهي وكيل بوزاره الثقافه والاعلام
للافغانيه يؤكد عمليات الدواعش بين حين
واخر ويصف اياها بانها متقطعه لا تؤدي الى
زعزعه الامن بحسب تعبيره
في بلد يعيش فيه اربعون مليون شخص من
الطبع ان تحدث فيها عمليه امنيه خلال شهر
ولن نستطيع وصف الوضع بان الامن انعدم
تماما فان مثل هذه العمليات قد تحدث في
جميع بلاد العالم
في عمليات مضاده نفذتها القوات الامنيه
خلال شهر فقط قتل ابو عبيده الكشميري امير
داعش لشبه القاره الهنديه والقارئ فاتح
مسؤول العمليات القتاليه
لداعش فرع خراسان
على الرغم من عمليات دمويه يقوم بها تنظيم
الداعش في البلاد فان السلطات في كابول لا
تعتبر التنظيم تهديدا خطرا وذلك لان عناصر
التنظيم لم تستطع السيطره حتى الان على
شبر من الاراضي الافغانيه عبد الاله نادر
العربيه كابول
استبدلت مجموعه هواوي الصينيه العملاقه
التي تكنولوجيا الالاف من مكوناتها التي
كانت ستستحصل عليها من الولايات المتحده
بمكونات صينيه الصنع وكانت هو وهي مورد
رائد لمعدات الاتصالات والهواتف الذكيه
وغيرها من المعدات المتطوره هدفا
لانتقادات واشنطن بشكل متكرر في السنوات
الاخيره بسبب مخاوفها تتعلق بالامن
السيبراني والتجسس
[موسيقى]
في استراليا نفقه الملايين من الاسماك
الميته التي جرفتها المياه الى نهر
دارلينج باكا واشارت التوقعات بان نفوق
الاسماك يعود الى الطقس الحار وانخفاض
مستويات الاكسجين حصار الفيضانات في
المنطقه والتي اكدت بشانها وزاره الصناعات
الاوليه في ولايه نيو سافويلز بان حاله
نفوق الاسماك ستستمر باستمرار مع موجه
الطقس الحال
ختام التاسعه مع العلم
امتثالا لمذكره محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وزير العدل الالمانيه تعهدوا باعتقال
بوتين اذا قرر الاخير زياره المانيا
المئات من جنود الاحتياط الاسرائيليين
يرفضون قرار استدعائهم وانا تنياهو يحذر
من حاله عصيان داخل الجيش
التاسع عشر من شهر اذار لعام 2023 توقيع
بغداد وطهران توقعان اتفاقيه امنيه تنص
على حمايه وضبط الحدود بين اقليم
الكردستان وايران
بعد دعوه للخروج منعا الاعتقاله البيت
الابيض يحذر من تكرار احداث الكابيتال في
السادس من يناير عام 2021
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
اخبار العربيه طبعا مستمره والان الى 360
والزميله رشا ماذا لديك مساء الخير اهلا
بك ليال مساء الخير سيكون لدينا التحدي
الروسيه على طريقه بوتين الذي قرر ولاول
مره منذ الحرب ان يزور ماريوبل يتفقد
الاماكن وايضا يتحدث مع القاده العسكريين
لدينا ايضا بمناسبه 20 عام على الحرب
الامريكيه في العراق هناك تقارير دوليه
تشير الى اصابه الجنود الامريكيين وايضا
المدنيين العراقيين بامراض تنافسيه نتيجه
حرق الوثائق الامريكيه تفضل
[موسيقى]